you've heard my price if it's too high
then with nothing left to discuss is it
gonna charity I have investors unlikely
and they expect a return call me when
you're serious payment received I'll
bring my best man
while my prep for Phase two
[Music]
not long after enlisting in the Indian
Armed Forces Kali was disappointed to
learn that women were not allowed to
serve in combat units prior to 1992
woman within the military served in
axillary services only undertaking more
of a support role shortly after leaving
the military Kylie used her family's
wealth and prestige to establish her own
private security company that would
operate inside India's borders to widen
the reach of her clientele Kylie then
founded the private military company
Knight Haven to operate overseas this
organization Wrigley negotiates
multi-million dollar contracts across
the globe in 2019 six invited Knight
Haven to join Team rainbow officially
this was in response to Knight Haven
answering a distress call on the super
tanker Argos we pirate to tech the ship
and threatened to kill everyone on board
because of night Haven the Pirates were
successfully neutralized without
incident however unbeknownst to them and
secretly the real reason six invited
Carly and why am I was to prevent any
opposing organization from hiring night
Haven and in this way not only could
these skills be utilized but they could
also be kept under close scrutiny
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
jhemini kylie mohan shah code-named
Kylie isn't attacking operator in team
rainbow born to exceptionally wealthy
parents money has never been an obstacle
for Kali as with wealth comes a vast
number of opportunities and resources
therefore it should be of no surprise
that she was able to achieve her goals
from a very young age reality came
crashing down when she tried to join the
military and discovered that women were
not entitled to serve in combat units
her interest in martial arts had led her
to enlist and despite all of her money
and social influence she had finally
found an obstacle between her and
something that she wanted because of
this she decided to create her own
private security company which would
operate within India's borders and
subsequently she then started an
overseas private military company Kylie
would the advantage of her considerable
wealth has managed to work her way
around the laws that have kept different
McCall's
she has become an unstoppable force in a
largely stetic male-dominated world her
viciousness is legendary and she's
considered a valuable resource that the
Indian government cannot do without as a
child she was given everything that she
wanted without question from appearance
and she is both arrogant and ambitious
but not without good reason
she drives those under a command above
and beyond this psychological and
physical breaking points in order to
help them achieve greater heights than
they would have ever thought possible
because of this she excels as a leader
in fact those that complete the training
are often been inducted into her inner
circle a society of protectors as she
calls it to the exceptionally rich
borders and merely suggestions and for
this reason it can be difficult to tell
with this she has any sort of patriotism
but the name Kali and a brutality
towards those who cross her imply
connection with the country and religion
she is said to be nicknamed under the
Hindu goddess of death time and doomsday
who was often associated with sexuality
and violence but has also considered a
strong mother figure and symbol of
motherly love her lack of clarity in
regards to her motivations has already
put her adults with specialist Ashe as a
Chaisson who lives by a very strict set
of rules and Kylie's very existence
calls many of Ash's beliefs into
Christian it's important to mention that
Carly has a number of strengths and she
hasn't just set back the whole time and
coasted through life because of her
family's exists she is also brave and
cunning smart and driven her training
systems are relentless and is
supplemented by some of the best
trainers and equipment that money can
buy
Carly is equipped with an underbarrel
mechanical projectile that explodes
within a set radius it is used to
destroy gadgets on both sides of
breakable and reinforced surfaces called
the LV explosive Lance it isn't your
typical explosive it can breach
barricades and hatches but it can also
destroy castles armored panels however
these are not its main functions its
main role is to destroy gadgets with a
light explosion within a set radius when
used in a breakable wall will create a
small hole when shown it a reinforced
wall however it simply lodges in the
surface in both cases it destroys all
gadgets on either side of the wall
[Music]
ug mucho ki Ferrara code-named y mi is a
defending operator and team rainbow born
in Kenya he is part of a fishing family
and spent a vast amount of his childhood
hunting sharks and collecting lost
treasures from the ocean floor of la mu
archipelago it became apparent from very
early on that WOM I was able to stay
underwater for far longer periods of
time than his peers a number of medical
tests were performed on them and
revealed an exceptional morphology in
regards to how his body exchanges gases
there's only helped to further enhance
his long-held belief that he was an
exceptional being compared to others
around him
armed with displacing why am i put his
skills to good use and join the Kenyan
Navy and later the Kenyan Special Boat
unit during this time he became well
known by a number of prominent Navy
generals along with people from the
scientific community for his
record-breaking three days he later
transitioned to night Haven drawn and by
the promise of more down time and the
use of a private boat to take him to
whereever as Nick's dive site might be
there is certainly an out-of-this-world
feeling - specialist hua Mei and the
name hua Mei means to come from the
water and it's fair to say that talking
to him is like talking underwater words
are exchanged however if it's uncertain
as to what he really means he is the
capability to move freely for one
abstract topic to another although this
isn't to say that he's oblivious to the
fact that others are likely to get lost
trying to follow his thought process and
will often rein it in when he seems to
veer off course too much for his
audience
armed with the ability to conceptualize
in a 3d space around him
both vertically and horizontally his
unaccustomed approach often results and
strategies that are completely alien to
others this type of thinking is usually
only seen in the most obsessive fighter
pilots interestingly though even with
all his unconventional intelligence he
for some reason still has trouble
grasping the inner workings of himself
than others
while my is a talented operator
intelligent capable and unpredictable is
the ability to put a room at ease with
his cool and calm collected nature which
has proven to be invaluable in tough
situations yet no one ever has the sense
that they understand the whole picture
when conversing with them he is a strong
belief that his life is in service to
his own spirituality and is constantly
striving for the pursuit of complete
zero or nothingness
like the nitrogen that must disperse
back into the divers body before
resurfacing while Maya's true nature is
widespread to define him would be to
limit him something that he despised
more than anything
while my is equipped with an adhesive
gadget that affects and captures an
opponent's projectile and then
self-destructs to detonate it the magnet
system is a throwin adhesive gadget it
sticks to surfaces and walls its
function is to attract an opponent's
projectile into its position reset the
destination timer and an exploding net
projectile this way not only can while
mine make attackers grenades in
projectile gadgets useless but you can
also use strategic placement to turn
those projectiles against them I gotta
be honest why am I creeps me out a
little I mean I like weird but that dude
is next-level I've been keeping a pretty
close eye on all the information coming
out regarding the future of siege and
I'm certainly happy to see the amount of
lore and story they seem to be including
from an ex each video I'm going to be
taking it back a little closer to home
the Australian Special Air Service
regiment or SAS are surely aren't bunch
of these names to bed actually it'll
probably be a bit of a challenge for me
not to add too much for nosy twang
anyway thank you very much for watching
please check out my various social media
platforms and firm your like follow
subscribe or swipe right to feed my
fragile content creator ego Cheers